hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will be
your driver on this journey
um all right everyone uh it's another
one of those nights where ben simon has
left me to produce an
actual show involving i think some music
some sort of concert
and the intro music is still playing i'm
to turn it off now
goodbye to the intro music so i'm rough
and tumbling it
uh all here on my own and today
what we are going to talk about is
influencers in chess and no i am not
talking about
you know uh alexander botez akaro
nakamura these
famous people on twitch that are uh
you know growing the game of chess as
they say i am talking about chess
players throughout history
that have had a major impact on chess
strategy
uh players that have changed the way uh
that's
you know chess players as a whole have
viewed the game of chess
and ideas and who better to start with
than the one and only
tigran petrosian of course i am talking
about
tigran vardanovich petrosian there are
many t-run protrusions but
this was the only one to become a world
champion
and uh when i say uh petrosian's name
there should be one idea in particular
that you kind of associate with the guy
uh that idea is of course
the idea of heating your rooks and
losing them
at every opportunity on purpose
petrosian in my opinion is one of the
first chess players to really fully
embrace this idea of the positional
exchange
sacrifice this guy would just throw away
his rooks
not for checkmate not to you know
horribly ruin the opponent's uh king
side or anything of that nature
he would just give up the rook
in order to uh you know just just be
down a rook
so let's take a look at one of those
positional exchange sacrifices against
bent larson and talk a little bit about
why this worked out for petrosian and
how this idea has evolved throughout
chess
so jumping into it here we have e4 by
bence
uh e6 by petrossian knight f3
d5 knight c3 so a two knights french
and then after knight f6 uh bent larson
unfortunately for those french defense
players out there did play e takes d5
and we find ourselves in the typically
boring
looking exchange french position so e
takes d5
and now d4 why is this scene as
typically boring
well it's because the pawn structure is
so symmetric
right we have both players with the same
claim in the center
each sharing a d-pawn uh
black goes for control over e4 white
goes for control over e5
but what truly makes this variation uh
so quote unquote boring
the reputation it has is because this
one long
open e file uh with only one open
central file on the board
very very often what you'll see is the
major pieces all end up getting traded
on this open e file so let's see how
this game progressed
but that is a little background on the
opening we saw c6 by petrossian just
supporting the center
bishop d3 by white bishop d6 castles
and castles so both players getting off
of this open file with their kings
uh now ben larson went for an
interesting idea he started bringing
this knight over around
to the king's side with knight e2 also
of course
freeing up the c pawn for a little
mobility uh petrosian played very
naturally he brought his rook to the
open file
knight g3 now by white knight beat d7
petrossian just getting developed
you'll often see by the way that this
bishop on c8 is the last piece that gets
developed for black in many many
openings
and the point there is that this bishop
actually is doing quite a lot on c8
controlling this open diagonal
and sometimes it's better to just leave
it there for a little bit
rather than bring it out to a square
like g4 where it can quite easily be
kicked around
so trojan leaving this bishop on c8 for
the moment
we see knight f5 by ben larson
and nowadays sometimes you might expect
players
to drop this bishop back to c7 drop it
back to
f8 you know doing what they can to
preserve this bishop but petrosian
actually gave up the bishop with knight
f8
um allowing white to capture on d6 and
now queen takes d6
and i think a lot of players today would
sort of hate allowing this exchange
but i don't think this is too bad for
black at at all
now with the dark squared bishop off the
board white tries to occupy
this e5 square uh
protrusion not wanting to give up on the
square so easily plays the move knight 6
to d5 or sorry knight 6 to d7
and now after bishop d2 i would like you
guys at home
to try and come up with some ideas here
for black of course this is
a position pretty early on
in the opening but already here you
should be focused on one thing in
particular and deciding how you want to
deal with it so what do you think is
going on here
he didn't play rook takes c5 manny is a
little bit ahead of the game
and ahead of the class perhaps but we'll
see
yeah chess king says bishop of fate
looked good bishop f8 was perfectly fine
as was bishop c7 just preserving the
bishop but
pretrojan chose to gave up to give up
this piece instead
so what are you guys thinking about out
there
what ideas uh are running through your
head
chess king likes knight g6 so in general
the thing to be focused on is this
knight on e5 this is clearly a very very
strong piece
for white you should be looking for ways
to get rid of it
um probably a question you guys should
be asking is well why can't i take this
pawn
and while the reason is there's a rookie
one tactic when unfortunately for you
you are not going to be able to save
this rook
similarly if rook takes there is of
course bishop f4
and perhaps this would be in the style
of protrusion but we're going to get
there
in just a moment um so chess king chose
the move knight g6 and i think this
makes sense
the danger you would run into with a
move like knight g6
is that f4 might cement this knight
rather solidly on the e5 square and you
might regret not getting rid of it while
you had the chance
so in the game the idea that petrosian
actually came up with
was to play this move f6 right away
and uh this is a pretty you know
combative idea here
you are of course weakening these light
squares around your king
in order to directly challenge this
knight
uh so queen h5 was played by
whites and then i'm sure some of you
would be able to guess
petrosian's next move after queen h5
taking advantage of the facts by the way
that f6
weakened your light squares
what does petrosian do here
so yeah of course chess king has the
right answer here
the move rookie 7 might objectively be
the best move
but this is patron we're talking about
this guy hates his rooks and he plays
rook takes e5 and now after d takes e5
we have f takes e5 and
of course the title of this lecture is
um i don't remember but something to do
with influencers of chess strategy
and this is an idea that has sort of uh
made its way into the current body of
chess thinking right
i think in the olden days players
thought rooks were just so so superior
to minor pieces that they were often
unwilling
to give them up for these sort of
strange-looking types of
compensations but these days
i think at the top level one pawn
and a minor piece for the rook is often
seen
as you know almost equality certainly
enough to draw
in an end game type scenario so
here petrosian already has one pawn and
a knight for the exchange
and in addition he's going to get a ton
of middle game
benefits by having this strong
uncontested
uh center something like well i did
write the title today
but i didn't remember exactly what i
wrote but why not knight g7
i think you mean knight g6 and
unfortunately knight g6 would run into
just knight takes
when you are checkmated in short order
uh kaushik
checkmated it's tough um but yeah
so we see trojan doing his classic
exchange sacrifice here getting two
pawns in the center
in exchange for the exchange
uh in this case though i i do have to
admit objectively
i don't think this is the greatest
position in the world
for black the reason for that being
two bishops are usually pretty good uh
and
you know to only get the the two knights
in exchange for a bishop at
rook is quite often not ideal uh
additionally
i think white does have some ideas of
playing against
these central pawns so now with the
white pieces here what do you think
bent larson should have been considering
in order to
try and fight back against these strong
central pawns
well it's the computer evaluation for
this well i have taken taken a look at
this game with a computer
and it does pretty heavily favor whites
uh plus 1.5 or so
so even though objectively uh well at
least according to the computer
this is pretty good for whites um i want
to take a look at the rest of this game
still and see how petrosian
managed to use these central pawns to
his advantage because
sort of a two-step process here right
you know the step one is pretty easy you
sacrifice the exchange
step two is is you know using those
pawns to your advantage and that's what
petrosian was so good at and that's why
these ideas sort of
persisted because petrosian was showing
sort of the correct ways
to play with the pawns
so i think you guys are a little bit on
the wrong track here
um saying moves like f4 or c4
you know this is sort of the traditional
way to break down pawns right you
you challenge them at you know uh
you just challenge them right you use
your pawns to challenge them and hope to
break them up
right but in this case i think white
should be more focused on containing
these pawns if you play a move like f4
especially you're gonna run into e4
and after bishop e2 now these pawns are
going to be very powerful
and if black ever gets to play the move
d4 then you know they're only going to
grow stronger
and there's even tactics like like this
in the position as
as well so you have to be very very
careful here same deal
with something like c4 uh you're sort of
just running into e4
and not d4 immediately but something
like knight f6
uh let's say the queen retreats to d1
for example and then and then something
like d4
and if these pawns get rolling then
white definitely isn't going to be
better
so i think what white should should have
focused on instead are moves like c3 or
f3 not so much trying to challenge these
central pawns but just contain them for
the moment right this pawn is
for the moment on the e5 square not
defended by the other pawns
so if white can apply a little bit of
pressure to this pawn and sort of
bait black into playing a move like d4
then i think black is going to be
saddled with sort of a weakness here
it's going to be tough going to be tough
so moves like f3 and c3
or a move like what was played in the
game rook f to e1
i think it was perfectly fine for white
the idea being
you're just trying to contain these
pawns not launching these pawns at the
center but
leaving them back a little bit allowing
you to
try and contain them on this third rank
e4 by petrossian is still perfectly
natural
and for this reason maybe i would have
liked the immediate f3
but that's okay e4 played bishop f1
and now knight f6 but trojan just uh
easily
develops his remaining pieces thanks to
a strong central advantage
queen h4 bishop f5 queen g3
and queen e7 so protrosian is not so
interested
in trading queens in this position why
is that well his advantage
is in the center he has a ton of central
space that's limiting his opponent's
pieces for the moment
and that central space is not going to
be as useful if he were to trade into
some kind of
end game right then his opponent's
pieces uh
well first of all there would be less of
them and it would be a little bit easier
to activate them
in an end game than in this middle game
position so queen e7 keeping pieces on
the board
and c3 now by bent is doing this uh sort
of containment
idea trying to contain these central
pawns
black continues developing now with
knight e6
and this is really the huge benefit
to the way petrosian decided to play
this position if you take a look at
you know something like six moves ago
these knights are stepping on each
other's toes
this knight is never coming here this
bishop isn't getting developed
this knight is like i said sort of
getting stepped on by the other knight
there's it's very difficult to use these
light squares
on the king side for black thanks to
this bishop and then fast forwarding
six moves we see this pawn land on e4
this knight can step to f6 now
this knight can this bishop can develop
this knight can come to e6
and all of black's pieces have a purpose
so
that is sort of the root idea of this
exchange sacrifice in this game black's
position was actually pretty awkward
out of the opening with all of his
pieces sort of stuck uh behind each
other
and by sacrificing this this exchange
protrusion gets the center
and once he has the center it's very
easy to develop the pieces and make sure
they are useful
okay continuing on we see bishop e3 here
and now knight g4
and look at these monster knights by
petrosian uh the center is controlling
all of
all of the light squares and these
knights are controlling all of the dark
squares like look at this it's just
total
total control you can even you can't
even see past all the arrows that's how
many squares petrossian controls
and yeah that is the benefit to having a
strong center
so now white is forced to part with the
bishops because
if he doesn't part with the bishops then
his bishops are going to be stuck on c1
and f1 doing nothing
so h3 was played in the game we see
knight e3 and rook e3
now petrossian activates his final piece
by bringing this rook
to the uh only half open file for black
on the board
uh queen e5 now is maintaining this
active queen
and petrossian simply retreats slamming
them keys it's with
authority wicked you gotta play the next
move all right rook d1
on the board and now after queen f7 we
see that the space advantage has
resulted in white having to deal with
sort of a weakness here
on f2 right thanks to this pawn on e4
this
pawn is a little bit stuck back here on
the f2 square
and black is trying to take advantage of
this rook d2 is played in the game
and now after knight f4 we see once
again
that a few sort of natural looking moves
by
white later and i don't think black is
even worse
in this position in fact i very much
would prefer to have the black pieces
here
in in a practical game um
why is that well it's because white's
rooks are doing nothing
but trying to stop these central pawns
from rolling forwards
black is the one pressuring weakness and
black's pieces
all have very good squares to uh to jump
to uh b4 was played in the game
by ben larson and now petrosian realizes
the that he is in absolutely no rush and
plays the move h6
just to give his king this little uh
flight square a4
by ben larson trying to expand on the
queen side to gain some play for himself
bishop h7 now
is tucking this bishop away sorry i know
i said it was for the king but it was
for the bishop as well
uh queen d4 b6 by
uh petrossian now rookie one queen c7
queen e3
and then i would like you guys to find
uh petrosian's
next move what is petrossian's idea here
what's to be done
he succeeded in getting a very good
uh position with the essential pawns but
now how do you make progress right
because he wasn't really making progress
on this f pawn
this piece was more than enough to
defend it so how do you make progress
here
odysseus has the idea of playing
g5 and let me actually do this really
quick
sorry flip that around
how do you try to make progress with
black here
so manny says a5 odysseus says g5 manny
says maybe c5
knight d3 has been suggested g5 king h8
and just attack
you guys are killers out there
killers in the chat room
so there are a few ways you can take
advantage of having a strong
central advantage and i've actually
talked about this in a previous lecture
i think
so uh way number one is by occupying the
center
with so much force it can be difficult
for your opponent to sort of switch
sides of the board right
if your central advantage is as in this
case
uh is pointing towards the king side
then you're gonna have some more king
side space
and very often you can organize some
kind of attack based on this spatial
advantage so that's what you guys are
saying
as you're saying launch pawns g5 king h8
you know
go g4 try to checkmate the guy and i
think that's a valid way of playing
um that's a perfectly valid way of
trying to make use of these central
pawns
however in this game i wasn't even
intending to draw this arrow but it was
just so natural that it had to be done
petrosian tried to press his central
advantage in another way
the other way to press the central
advantage is to start pushing it up the
board
until those pawns that were strong in
the center turn into queens at the end
of the board
and i think that might be the better
plan
in this case just because it happens a
little bit more naturally and a little
bit more
more freely that's not to say that this
plan is wrong i think a move
like uh king h8 and doing stuff like g5
maybe a little bit later
is a you know a valid way of playing you
do just have to be careful about this
diagonal a little bit
but yeah moves like rook f5 i don't hate
at all
for black but i do think that c5 is the
way to go here and this is what uh
what protrosian does a5 or c5 better so
black's goal is not to break down
white's pawns here it's to advance
these central pawns with ideas of d4
later to come
and so i think c5 is definitely the
the best move here right taking
advantage of
his central control controlling yet
another central square
and keeping ideas of pushing d4 alive a
little bit later in the game
uh white took on c5 black recaptures and
now we see g3
by white and i think this is sort of
white's uh
big mistake in the game i think uh white
could have had chances for an advantage
still if he goes rook b1
and tries to take advantage of this
newly opened b file looking to step to
squares like b5
uh pressuring black's center but after
d3 or g3 we see knight d3
and takes takes and now uh black's pawns
are going to be
strong enough i believe i think
white's last chance for equality was
sort of here when he could give back the
exchange by capturing on d3
and just play this end game i think
practically i would rather be black here
with ideas of d4 to come but objectively
it should just be a draw
here though uh white went for more with
queen e6 check
and now after queen f7 to keep the pawn
we see captures captures
rook b2 and now c4
and the exchange is sort of meaningless
uh when compared to this pawn on d3
right you're never going to be able to
activate the rooks effectively
while they're having to sort of stay
behind and keep an eye on this d3 pawn
and then protrosian goes on to win this
game without too much difficulty
f3 was played d4 uh is
of course a a key idea i probably should
have asked the chat
to find that one uh forgot that it
happened immediately but of course
it's this idea of breaking through in
the end game
that we've seen before where the c3 pawn
is sort of the last
uh stand for white against these
powerful
c and d pawns on c4 and d3 and so d4 is
is a perfect idea to break through here
rook c1 was white's try of course this
is
suicide uh to allow these pawns to the
the third rank
so rook c1 and then petrossian brings
the king into the game
and it's just domination here
just domination nothing to be done
c3 d2 and
uh ben larson went ahead and resigned
this position
so this game uh in particular was a very
nice game
but this idea on the whole was played in
many many many of petrosian's games
this guy absolutely hated his rooks and
would give them away
that's sort of any opportunity and then
especially this idea of
you know giving up a rook for this
central advantage is something that i
think petrosian really pioneered and
it's idea
an idea that definitely persists in
modern chess today
uh so any questions on on this game in
particular
any questions here before i go ahead and
move on
of course the influential idea once
again from this game
the central rook exchange sacrifice
really cool stuff but this stack was
probably not really worth it
well yeah it's this game was less about
the sack being great and more about
petrossian's play after the sacrifice
being really really phenomenal uh it
perfectly shows
how to use this central advantage to
push it up the board
and get to a
get to a winning position came late what
was the opening it was an exchange
friends
french well a two nights french which
turned into an exchange i don't know
the naming scheme for those show the
game very fast we'll rewind sicilian
dragon
i will review really fast we had this
opening
that i mentioned and then the key moment
here
comes after the oh not this this is not
what was played
comes after the idea of f6 queen h5 and
rook takes e5
getting this strong central advantage
and here i think the simplest way for
white to play
would be with f3 and then petrosian
might have a little bit more of a
difficult time
breaking through with these e4 ideas
what year is this game i think 1966
three it's 1960 something i i'm sorry i
don't fully recall
um okay with that in mind let
us switch to this view aha and i will
get ready to show you guys
the next game so i actually do have the
info by the way it was 1966 in havana
cuba uh white never had the advantage
white did have the advantage
after the exchange sacrifice but then it
slowly sort of turned
into black's favor with some accurate
play
okay so i have a question chat room when
i say to you
uh who was the first real modern day
chess player and when i say modern day
chess player i want you to think of guys
like magnus carlsen fabiano carowanna
right
i think those guys have this sort of
distinct
style of playing chess that sort of
didn't exist back in gary kasparov's
time like kasparov was great
but he definitely wasn't in this
computer era of chess that we live in
now
uh that has the utmost accuracy tons of
opening preparation
and things of this nature so postgary
kasparov is what i'm calling
modern chess players who are your
candidates for sort of the first
innovators in this style who do you got
gabriel harris says anand anand would be
a very good candidate anand would be a
good candidate botfonik too old
too old all right everybody's saying
vichy cram nick
that was the name i was looking for by
thotty i think vishyanan would be a very
good candidate by the way
uh definitely a highly influential chess
player
but in my opinion this is my opinion no
one has had a more
distinct clear traceable influence on
modern day chess
than one vlady kramnik and
i am going to show you guys a game that
you uh
will probably hate kramnik for because
here we go gary kasparov against
vladimir kramnik
back in the year 2000 is our next game
to go over
and yes it was a draw and
i think that this game is proof in and
of itself
of kramnik's influence it has been
literally 20 years
since this game was played and
vlad's uh vlad kramnik's opening choice
in this game
has very truly changed the face of chess
uh sort of irreversibly forever right
this game and the games in this match
are sort of the reason why
uh e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 is no longer really the most
common opening that you see
from the white pieces at the top level
it's because of this game
because of course players at the top
level are terrified
of the berlin wall right we see
in this game bishop b5 everybody's
favorite move knight f6
and this was really an innovation that
kramnik
uh was championing in this year 2000
match right
this is where it kind of broke into the
the total top level this is the world
championship match or
the classical world championship the
classical chess champ whatever you want
to call it this was during that weird
time
when the the championships were split
and yeah kramnik
started playing the berlin and kasparov
just was never close
to uh to beating him in this berlin and
since then
since that fateful day in the year 2000
people just started playing the berlin
everywhere
and uh and yeah and that's
just a small part of kramnik's influence
on chess but let's take a look at the
game
of course the berlin uh occurs after the
move
three knight f6 and kasparov was trying
the end game line
in the match with castles knight takes
e4 and d4
black retreats this knight to d6 of
course you cannot do things like capture
here
because of the pin on the knight so
knight d6
we see captures captures and white
regains this pawn
knight f5 and then we arrive at the
berlin end game by
queen takes d8 and king takes d8 and
now uh optically i would say this looks
very promising
for white i'm not going to go into
super super deep detail on the berlin
end game i have done
a full lecture on this end game if
you're interested just search it up on
youtube i've done lectures on everything
at this point
but basically optically you would think
this is very good for white he has this
e5 pawn
sort of in exchange for this c6 pawn
right black having this double pawn on
the queen side makes you think it's not
going to be very useful
whereas you know you can imagine some
fateful day pawns land on f5 and g4 and
then this palm looks very very imposing
on e5 but of course black here has the
two bishops
and in addition to that he's going to
have a very safe king
either on the queen side or by bringing
it back to e8
and this e5 pawn might prove not to be a
little bit weak in some cases
as well what if white doesn't exchange
queens well if white didn't want to
exchange queens probably this is not the
ideal line to go for
i think like queenie 2 is technically
playable here but if you didn't want to
exchange queens you probably should have
deviated a little bit earlier
with something like d3 here for example
or in this case you can play rookie 1 as
well and keep queens on the board
but this line i think is even more drawn
but yeah once you get to this point
white should probably just trade the
queens
um so knight c3 was kasparov's choice in
the game and kramnik just develops this
bishop with bishop d7
blocking off this file and giving the
king access to c8
b3 was played h6 was kramnik's choice in
this match
uh bishop b2 gets developed for kasparov
and now king c8 and kramnik very calmly
exits the d file did kasparov ever try
the ante berlin in this match i'm pretty
sure he played the end game line
in all four games where uh kramnik
berlin was tested
and like i said never made anything
close to progress
usually only white looks to win yeah no
but
uh there are tons and tons of games
where white tries to overpress
and black does does end up winning
h3 to a4
not 100 certain what you're talking
about slaying dragons um yeah h3
uh can be played i don't think a4 is
really a move here but
uh anyways kasparov did normal chess and
just developed this rook to the d
file we see now b6 for black 92 for
white
and c5 for kramnik and we're starting to
see
that's uh despite this e5 pawn not being
doubled
sometimes the c5 pawn actually does end
up being the more
useful thing oh anti berlin so yeah
earlier on there are plenty of options
to to avoid the berlin
and avoid the berlin end game but
not to be done here by gary
so i was as i was saying we are starting
to see that the c5 pawn might actually
be a bit more useful
than e5 all of white's pieces
would love to use this square but none
of them can because the c5 pawn is just
too strong
and the backup c pawn on c7 is also
serving an important role
making sure that this d6 square is
defended and yeah providing some lateral
defense
from anything on the seventh rank once
this king lands on b7
c4 now by white stops this pawn in its
trash
tracks but now bishop c6 and
yeah black black just doesn't have
problems in this position
and that's why uh players today are
having such a difficult time
uh defeating the berlin knight f4
was white's choice he tries to bring
this the his second knight over to the
king side
and sort of just focus his pieces on
this side of the board right he wants to
focus on the king's side
try to make this e pawn worth something
black now plays king b7
and this is sort of my my feeling
in some end games in the berlin right
you you take a look here
and it's like well black is so far up
behind in development all of white's
pieces
are out this works on an open file
black's king and black's dark squared
bishop are both
stuck on the back rank the king can't
leave until this bishop is defended
but then all of a sudden this sort of
timer starts where black plays one
useful move after another
and it's like yeah if you haven't done
anything by the time i get developed
then you have absolutely nothing here
and so black has already
nearly completed his development and
what has white done in the meantime
he's played c4 he's put a knight on f4
and
i am quite frankly just not impressed
uh knight d5 comes on the board but now
kramnik is able to challenge this knight
very directly with the move knight e7
rook fe-1 is played and kramnik now just
plays this mover g8
steps this rook off the long open
diagonal provides some support for this
pawn
and allows white to play his next move
so
knight f4 was gary kasparov's choice
realizing that this knight on d5
was not actually achieving too much and
what do you think
kramnik should do in response to this
move knight f4
what should kramnik do in response
so yeah chess king has the right idea
here and the chat room is sort of on the
right track
this move e6 can look a little bit scary
right that's that's a way for white to
try and make this pawn useful right
pushing it to e6
i'm not sure was ever really possible uh
in this case
but uh after knight f4 white could very
seriously be considering playing a move
like
like e6 for example if we just pass
something like a6
already e6 could be quite annoying if we
end up taking this pawn
knight e5 and this pawn is definitely
not going to stick around forever
if we move this bishop out of the way
for example knight takes e6
and white's activity is starting to look
a little bit scary although it's a
little bit unclear
if white is even better if he gets all
of this
um here though of course kramnik chooses
this move g5 and this
sort of prevents this idea of e6 knight
h5 appears on the board
and then kramnik plays the safe move
rook g6
really making sure he has a good hold on
this e6 square
why is this good for black it's not
great for black
but it's just not bad for black right
you know what can white do to win this
chess game and the answer is
is really not anything um knight f6 was
tried
and yeah white's pieces look active but
they really don't do anything
this is the issue bishop g7 now by
kramnik
contest this knight on f6 rook d3
by kasparov uh guards this knight on f3
against any bishop takes knight ideas
if i could draw an arrow and also
prepares to double if necessary
and then kramnik just simplifies he
takes on f3
takes on f6 and goes knight c6 and
now this f6 pawn once again looks
dangerous
but it's this classic berlin problem
where white just can't really
can't really do anything there's nothing
to do against the berlin it's just awful
it's an awful awful opening rook d3 was
tried to try and
invade down here on d7 but kramnik
preemptively plays rook f8
and then says yeah good luck if you want
to come to d7
i can always kick you out with something
like king c8
if you defend well good luck something
like knight b8 at worst case
sorry not ticks something like here it's
like yeah what are you going to do
what are you going to do buddy what are
you going to do so
rookie 4 was tried and said by kasparov
now king c8
prevents this rick from ever landing on
d7 f4
is kasparov's choice kramnik takes we
see rook takes
on f4 and now i would
dare say that black is uh approaching
being better
in this position he honestly is right
we saw black now take over this e file
bishop c3
and invade with this rick over to e2
kasparov suddenly on the back foot tries
rook f2
we see kramen to keep this piece on the
board rook h3
and now finally with the black pieces
kramnik can start
trying to press for an advantage so how
should he do that
how do you ever try to press for an
advantage in this position
with black kramnik has successfully
sort of warded off all of the white
pieces from invading on the seventh rank
uh this pawn on f6 looks very far
advanced and very dangerous but it could
easily
become a weakness after something like
knight d4 and when this pawn would have
to be defended by the major pieces
but how do you press now how do you try
to press
chess king says just don't
so yeah knight d4 isn't a bad move at
all 95 isn't a bad move either
these are definitely perfectly fine
moves but yeah the idea i'm looking for
is to provoke some weaknesses on the
queen side of the board
it's not winning for black by any means
in fact
objectively the position is probably
just a draw uh
but i think this move a5 is the best way
to practically play for an advantage
you're just sort of baiting your
opponent
and creating some weaknesses over here
right a4 is definitely not the happiest
move weakening the b3 pawn
and after a4 a takes b3 a takes b3
uh white might find himself with a small
small weakness here on b3
especially in light of the fact that the
b3 pawn is attacked by the move
knight to d4 in the game uh kes
sparrow chose the move rook h5 and now
vladi
does continue with the move a4
uh kasparov now makes a pretty serious
mistake i would say rather than allow a
takes b3 a takes b3 knight d4
he chose to take on a4 instead but i
think black is very significantly better
now
rook takes c4 played in the game bishop
d2 rook takes a4
rook takes h6 uh and then kramnik i
think sort of missteps here i think he
would have had a very
serious chance of winning this game had
he captured on
h6 and started pushing this pawn
advantage on the queen side with
something like c4
right of course this is going to be
rather double edged with white pushing
as well
for example c3 h5 things like this
but i definitely think black is going to
be on the better side of
of this end game um why is that
well it's a lot of specifics and also
there are some ideas of just
this if you go for this and if you play
the move g3 which looks a little a
little bit more natural
then and then uh you're just going to be
behind in this race right like c2 is
coming very quickly
rook takes c2 rook takes a2 knight b3
and it's going to be uh going to be
quite dangerous for white
in the game though kramnik chose to keep
this rook on the board with rook g8 and
after this
kasparov uh i think is in no real danger
there are some tactical complications uh
rook h7 was played
and yeah we would love to play rook f8
but
maybe it's just a bit too slow right
white is going to start pushing these
pawns
and black is now sort of behind in the
race because rather than capture capture
and push
he chose to spend a couple tempi to
preserve this rook
so rook takes a2 was played instead uh
kramnik just capturing this pawn
outright
rook takes f7 was played and now kramnik
does have to be a bit accurate here
he finds the move knight e5 hitting the
rook rook g7 rook f8
and now after something like f7
uh kramnik could immediately win the
pawn with rook a1 to f1 and then
captures so f7 is unplayable
which is why h3 was chosen to give the
king a flight square
and now kramnik does push with c4 rookie
7
knight d3 hits this guy f7
uh was kasparov's try but now the
tactics do work out to be a draw
knight takes f2 check king d7 rook takes
f8
and the key move here is king e7 and the
f
pawn falls at the end of the day
we end up in an end game where
white is up a pawn but it's not going to
be enough for a victory
we see them trade down into this drawn
uh rook and pawn end game
and the draw was agreed uh here
and the draw was agreed here so
why is this one of the most influential
games on chess
well because this is one of the early
examples of the berlin
being shown off at the top level of
course i'm not trying to say kramnik
invented the berlin but i think he
definitely
was the one to popularize it at the top
level and he was first playing it
in this match against gary kasparov by
the way a match which he won
rather convincingly without losing a
single
chess game so okay
all right earlier on i asked who you
guys thought was
the first modern chess player and i
added a lot of qualifiers
like you know uh after gary kasparov and
stuff
and one of the people in the chat
mentioned a player by the name of
mikhail
bot vinnick and that is the player i
want to take
a look at next uh botfinec of course
i think it is fair to argue was
one of the uh first real kind of modern
day chess players
now why is that well modern day chess
is sort of very distinct from the way
chess was
back in the day because players are so
much better at one particular aspect
of the game if you look at players from
the 1800s early 1900s
boy oh boy did they love to attack but
they did not love
as much to defend and i think
one of the first really really stellar
defenders
was mikhail bodfenik of course much of
his career was characterized by a
rivalry
with michael tal two very very different
styles
of chess play and bot finick was often
finding himself
on the defense against mikhail tal and i
wanted to highlight one of those games
where
botfunic uh went up against you know the
the beast
uh the beast known as tal the tactical
masterminds
and just easily uh sort of dismantled
any attacking ideas that tao could come
up with
and uh defeated him so let
us take a look here let me click on over
and we shall see
so this game is actually taken from the
1961
world championship match of course tal
dethroned botfinic
back in uh 1960 and bot finnick
got his rematch try in 1961.
didn't botfunic predate kasparov is that
modern well it's
uh botfinic is a player whose
influence can be seen in modern chess i
wouldn't say botfinec was really
a modern player by any stretch uh i
think back in the 1960s chess was
still pretty different than the chess we
see today and i think really kramnik
anand
those were the first real players of the
type of chess that we are looking at
um in 2020. however botfnik as i said
was one of those first players to really
excel at the idea
of defense yeah father of the russian
chess school
uh at least one of them and it's this
idea of uh excelling in defense that i
think botfinik
sort of introduced to the game along
with you know a few other players
it's an alaska introduced defense i
there's a lot of arguments to be had
botfinec was definitely one of the
stellar defenders uh
in chess history and uh i wanted to
highlight one of his games
there were a lot of players who we could
have chosen for this but trojan as well
was well known for being super super
solid super unshakeable
but let's take a look at this game
because who doesn't love
a good old talbot finnick matchup
ariane is sure that lasker introduced it
yeah i'm not saying about finnick was
the first player to ever defend a chess
position
but he sort of has this modern
defending idea i think
okay so yeah this is talbot finnick way
back in 1961
which game is this this is round 18 that
i chose
and we see e4 in this case c6 botfinic a
big proponent of the caro khan
d4 d5 e5 bishop f5 so the advanced cairo
and then of course tal being the
aggressive player uh chooses this line
with h4 and we actually saw a lot of
this line
in the recent st louis rapid and blitz
where players with the black pieces
these days do tend to play this move
uh h5 but back in bot the next day i
think
h6 was a little bit more of uh what a
little bit of a more common response to
this h4
idea uh just tucking this bishop away
on h7 did i suggest h5 yet these days i
think h5 is just objectively a better
move
but h6 is sort of the more historic
the more historic move uh g4 is
tal's follow-up which is the main move
here and
rather than actually drop the bishop
back to h7 boffenex chose the d7 square
for this bishop and bishop h7
can run into a little bit of trouble by
abandoning this diagonal when the move
e6 could appear
so bishop back to d7 is botvinnik's
choice
uh c3 was now chosen by uh
the reigning world champion at the time
and botfinix strike strikes back in the
center
with c5 just classic karo khan stuff
we see bishop g2 by tal pressuring the
center a little bit
and e6 is simple enough to defend
knight e2 by tal getting developed now
and uh here i want to pause for a moment
and talk to you guys about botvanick
versus tal
so of course tal well-known incredible
attacker
botvanic well-known incredible defender
loved grinding out those end game
positions
a very you know by the book sort of
chess player
so if you're playing tal here what sort
of ideas are going through your mind
to already begin diffusing any sort of
attacking possibilities
by tau
what ideas are you considering here
already
there's a question why is the caracan
not used that much today i would argue
it
is used quite a bit today take a look at
the saint louis rapid and blitz like
half of the games
and the rapid portion were caros
almost half the games what's the point
of bringing out the bishop and then
retreating
well generally this bishop would like to
stay on uh
f5 in this case it retreated after this
move
g4 and i think black is trying to claim
that
white is actually creating some
weaknesses for himself over here
by playing h4 and g4 and that is the
purpose that the bishop served
on f5 kind of provoking these weaknesses
by by white
okay i'm actually seeing a lot of wrong
answers and
usually when i ask these questions you
guys uh
managed to like foil me by giving uh
answers that are like perfectly
reasonable but you know not the idea i
was looking for
but in this case you guys are saying
some pretty pretty sketchy stuff in the
chat here pretty sketchy stuff
in classical games i think you see it a
reasonable amount it's just not
uh it's just not the the most uh
trendy opening these days i would say so
wrong answers g5 i think just loses
tactically
this is a pin can't play g5 g6 i think
is definitely
headed in the wrong direction here you
don't really want to be touching
the king's side here that's where you
know stuff is stuff is going down
you know what i mean you have to be a
little bit on the lookout here
i have to be on the lookout uh knight c6
i think would be a pretty reasonable
move here
for black but it would sort of prevent
uh bot finick's idea in the game uh and
bob fenix idea in the game
is bishop b5 right this guy
just says yeah i will move my bishop
four times
and then after knight a3 it's like yeah
i just wanted to kill your knight
right all he does is moves the bishop
out and captures this net in e2 this
knight was going to be a very scary
attacker either from the g3 square
uh eyeing both h5 and f5 or from the f4
square
eyeing f5 as well as e6 as well as d5
right those are the sort of sacrificial
positions
where you you could expect tal to just
you know capture a d5 pawn sort of out
of nowhere
and so what does bob fenik do plays
bishop b5 knight a3 he captures on e2
right queen takes e2 seems like a bad
move it's actually perfectly fine for
black
it's actually just perfectly fine for
black here
and now with botfinic now that you've
seen his
idea how should bob continue here
i don't know am i telling you not to
move your pieces more than more than
once in the opening
because i think this is the type of
anti-opening principle chess
that you see all the time in uh
in modern chess now what do all modern
you know top grand masters share when
they break opening principles
they do it because they have a very very
clear idea
and yeah biofenix idea here is that
white has provoked
or white has created weaknesses for
himself by pushing all these pawns
and now all black needs to do in order
to have an advantage
is trade off these attacking pieces and
then
be very very much better in an end game
so what does he do now he takes on d4 c
takes d4
and captures this knight on a3 just
killing
all of white's attacking potential b
takes a3
and now knight c6 to challenge the
center and by the way i wanted to
mention earlier
i saw somebody suggesting the move c4
here as well which is definitely the
wrong wrong wrong way to go
if white is attacking you on the king
side the last thing you want to do
is close the center close the queen side
you want to open
up something for your own pieces on the
other side of the board so
back to the game though takes take six
take six knight c6
bishop e3 and uh now we see
queen a5 check by botfinek activating
the queen as well
king f1 knight g to e7 and
all of a sudden you start asking
yourself with the white pieces you know
sort of
what am i doing here right uh this
bishop is
staring at the d-pawn which is perfectly
you know solid
this bishop is staring at a different
d-pawn which is not going anywhere
either
this rook is not coming to the queen
side any time soon
and so uh tau tried rook b1 to attack
this pawn
and botfinix just plays rick b8 saying
okay i'll defend that guy
uh bishop h3 was tal's choice now still
trying to get something rolling here
but now queen a4 pressures this guy
uh and we actually see king g2 by oh no
no we don't sorry that would hang the
pawn we see rook d1
by uh tau and now bot finnick is like
yeah
all right i'll take a free pawn queen
takes a3
king g2 and now let's see if you guys
can find
bot finick's next move what's his next
move
so yeah queen takes a three was playable
on multiple moves manny
uh buffing just prioritized getting
developed a bit more quickly
because this weakness on a3 really
wasn't going to go anywhere
f5 has been suggested but it was given
three question marks by the person who
suggested it so i don't know if they
really believe in it
king d7 is suggested knight before
suggested
yeah what are you guys doing ariane has
the right idea black
is going to be better in all the end
games because white has made a ton of
weaknesses
so bob thinks like yeah let's just trade
queens right you know you're still
trying to attack me good luck with that
without the queens buddy so queen a6
is his choice and now if white tries to
avoid this trade
sort of asking for a little bit of
trouble here right this knight is going
to land on c4
and black's gonna start pushing wasting
just a bit too much time with moves like
queen d2
and so tal just takes an a6 and tries to
hold this end game
thanks to this weakness uh and pawn
structure
that black has accepted in order to
trade off the queens
however botvanic being botfinic was uh
able to win this game
quite convincingly uh white plays the
move h5
black plays king d7 now
why not take the pawn on a3 immediately
well black just prioritized development
a little bit right he played moves like
knight ge7 first and then had to respond
to some threats and now uh
now he is doing quite well in the end
game rook b1
rook b6 rook uh king g3 knight a5
and now tao actually is forced to
fix black's pawn structure with the idea
of rick takes b6
because if he doesn't then rick h to be
eights and black is taking over the b
file and invading on b2
and that's sort of a worst case scenario
here
for white so with the pawns fixed
now black has no trouble converting
still pressuring the d4 pawn
and we see shortly a trade of a knight
for a bishop
and this extra b pawn now is good enough
uh playing through these moves rather
quickly because we're running out of
time
and we see a little tactical idea here
of
knight takes e5 unveiling a threat to
the rook
rook d1 if rick e1 was tried then
king f6 i think would be enough you
can't actually take this because rick c4
is check and there's no way to stay in
contact with the rook
so rick d1 played in said king d6 and
now
here tal went ahead and threw in the
towel
hmm that was a bad pun that i did i
literally did not mean to say that
uh just down two pawns and a
a totally lost end game now
so why did i show this game to show off
some some of the influence that
botvinnik had on all of chess
well number one he broke opening
principles
uh in order to follow sort of
he started his middle game strategy
straight out of the opening rather than
focusing directly on those opening
principles you know develop the pieces
you know attack the center right away
right away right away instead he focused
on
understanding his opponent's middle game
plan and sacrifice some of those opening
principles such as not moving the same
piece twice
in order to uh get those middle game
advantages
in order to get those middle game
advantages and more than that
it shows his defensive capabilities
anticipating the attack
and prophylactically trading off those
pieces understanding
his opponent has created weaknesses and
then defeating
mikhail tal sort of without a fight all
right
any questions on the games we went over
today any questions on the games we went
over today
any questions at all
well with that let me switch to my
full camera look here i think that is
going
to uh to do it for us here on the road
2000 as always i will be doing
the end game class directly after
uh directly after this show ends
so if you just joined as rose did no
worries because we have another class
going on directly after this
and i'm gonna be showing you guys some
uh some interesting stuff
about winning end games with even
material i've done a lecture on it
before
but i have more ideas to show you and
more games more chess players it'll be a
great time
with all that in mind that does do it
for us here on the road 2000
once again thank you guys so much for
watching and i will see you
next time as i click
over to here
and do this outro
see you guys next time goodbye
you